i i want to make a quick announcement
okay myself if you would let me okay um
i started my own clothing brand oh did
you actually i'm wearing it right now oh
[ __ ] yeah i was gonna ask i was like
yeah yeah
so yeah i've been working on this for
like a year right uh in secret oh nice
yeah yeah yeah until now like they
didn't know about it i'm like oh what
so uh yeah uh by the time this episode
comes out it will be like pretty much
close to launch okay so i figured while
we're here i'll uh
just announce building up building up
hype nice nice
it's called nonsense okay i was gonna
ask if it's called [ __ ] that noise
so this is this is just uh this is just
one of them actually kai can you
upstairs and get uh the other shirt i
have
but yeah um so this episode is sponsored
by joey this episode is sponsored by me
yeah we're getting a card
yeah but um you know i figured
like this would be the perfect
opportunity to like announce it since
you guys don't know about it um yeah i
have another shirt here what made you
decide to start working on
um
i like drip yeah you know yeah and it's
like
there's a lot of drip i like and there's
a lot of drip i like wearing but like
you know what better way to sport out my
drip than to just
make
[Music]
i can call myself an entrepreneur
finally business starter
you're gonna put in your twitter yeah
yeah yeah of course i have to start
don't do that nonsense found them
i have to do that nonsense founder and
ceo but uh yeah so i've been working on
this brand thing for like a year now
sorry great pitch
thank you
but yeah i've been working on this for
like a year now um and you know like
i've always been known to like you know
wear good clothes yeah like i like you
know fashion i'm privileged i'm
privileged i'm privileged
but you know i've always been like
interested in like clothing like fashion
you know like streetwear stuff like that
so i was like yeah there's so much good
street wear out there
but like nothing that was like really
like speaking to me personally right
it's like there's a lot of good brands
and whatnot but it's like so i was just
like
i'll [ __ ] do it myself i'll make it a
pain in the ass yeah absolutely it was a
pain in the ass i've done it yeah yeah
so like um yeah so it's like a full-on
proper brand or anything and like the
one thing i was always scared of right
is like
whenever youtubers release clothes yeah
it's usually under the merch
yeah yeah right but like i didn't want
this to be much because it's like
because you know these designs and like
all the designs are going to be
releasing have nothing to do with me or
like the likeness of me or anything like
that yeah i wanted to just be like
something separate to me right they're
like in the case that like the anime man
or whatever just [ __ ] implodes in on
itself right in a couple of years time
that this can still be around right so
he's like i'm already not watching anime
exactly
it's
i'm like you know what like i'll i'll
try something new i'll try something
like challenging yeah yeah so uh yeah so
by the time
this episode is out like all the social
media stuff is probably ready to go we
literally didn't know about that we
didn't know anything
you don't know you don't understand how
hard it was to keep it a secret from
these guys i'm like joey's kept a secret
from us boys
like literally i started this before we
moved to this office are you serious
yeah like at the old office what yeah so
it's been like
over a year
so yeah i'm uh i'm i'm very passionate
about this and i wanted to do well
yeah and uh yeah i hope people like it
so check out nonsense it's uh i'm gonna
be and we're gonna be doing this thing
where we release a new design every
month okay like one new design a month
because i thought like originally i was
like should i do like the usual thing
where it's like oh i dropped you know
like a collection like a collection of
winter collection but i was like no i'm
selling it to people on the internet and
the people on the internet have the
[ __ ] attention span of a goldfish so
i'm like let's just like keep bringing
stuff out yeah yeah so keep the drip
dripping exactly keep it keep that tap
just slightly open
so that the water's just constantly
dripping you know
rather than keeping it close and then
suddenly being like here you know so
yeah that's the that's the plans for it
obviously i'm not like you know [ __ ]
quitting anything else this is just like
another thing i'm doing on the side so
hey if you like it then uh check it out
i guess and then hopefully pre-orders
will start soon was there anything that
was uh surprisingly difficult about
making your own clothing brand yeah
like well for one
like you know it everything's designed
by me but like i can't do like graphic
design yeah or you know like i can't do
like logo design and stuff like that
right so like even just coming up with
like you know just like the font and
stuff like that for nonsense and like uh
i don't know if the logo is anywhere but
like yeah like you know just something
like that right yeah even just coming up
with like that font took me like two
months well that's why graphic designers
are like a job
i basically just described what a
graphic designer is
like damn this [ __ ] hard
job they already got a job yeah right
because like you know i'm not used to
that with like video creating right yeah
usually it's like nine times out of ten
i think of an idea and then i try and
make it work and then whatever i have
you know i have to work with right
especially with the kind of content i
make so it's like you know even if it's
not like perfect perfect yeah i have to
get something out there right otherwise
i won't you know i'll have the [ __ ]
upload schedule of you know 2015 gart
essentially yeah yeah so it's like
but like with this
i have to like really be careful with it
because i don't want to get a design out
there and it just looks like [ __ ] yeah
you know because it's like my brand is
on the line essentially how many fonts
did you have to go through
uh
like
well i mean for one like the the actual
the official font for the brand is
completely custom yeah so i had to get
like a like a typographer not a not a
graphic designer
i have to find a typographer to be like
and like a font specialist to be like
here's the brand here's what the brand
is about here's the kind of designs i
want yeah uh can you come up with just
like a shitload of fonts yeah and we
literally went through about 100 fonts
and just decided that's what we want
because the thing about fonts is that
it's something that like most people
don't really appreciate or think about
until you have to choose one like i
remember like just having to choose one
just to use for my like my youtube
videos or just yeah right a logo or
something and i'm just like where the
[ __ ] do i even start and then you go
through like the photoshop like fun and
you like realize that's just calibrating
it
just lightly yeah yeah
yeah you talk to graphic designers and
they're just like they're just like
built different they see a font and like
like name the font yeah like they can
name the font they can name like the
exact kerning between yeah yeah yeah
it's like yeah that's like an eight
kerning right there it's like what the
[ __ ] is all this so like what that means
turning is like the space between
letters
so like i i got like a like you know
working with like a typographer and
everything like i gave like a whole new
appreciation for like graphic design and
typography because like yeah that shit's
hard as [ __ ] and i can see why you know
like in the case with like this for
example like just changing this spacing
the kerning between each of the letters
yeah makes like a completely different
design yeah and you wouldn't think
otherwise though when you make like a
youtube thumbnail right yeah like yeah
you just [ __ ] put the font there and
you're good right right kind of thing so
it's like it made me appreciate like
subtle design yeah if anything and like
you know because i'm kind of going with
like kind of a combination between like
streetwear but also loungewear right so
like you can wear this like outside of
course and you know be great but you can
also it's comfortable enough where you
can wear it inside yeah as well so for
for you for you weebs out there that
don't go outside
you can still wear it it's like the
longest trash taste ad we've ever done
right now